et bien sûr il ya cette réunion à 10
heures qu'on va suivre peut-être qu'il y
aura dénouement sortie de crise mais
pendant ce temps là il ya quand même des
inquiétudes concernant les réserves de
propane et les craintes de pénurie avec
moi nathalie st-pierre qui est
présidente de l'association canadienne
du propane madame st-pierre bonjour
bombe atomique et qu'en est il que les
portraits de la situation qu'on a en ce
samedi matin
bon alors globalement pour dire qu'il
veut avoir des pénuries probablement
dans plusieurs secteurs incluant secteur
du propane mais qu'on pense au chlore
pour le look on pense à des produits qui
servent par exemple pour les avions le
déclassement des avions etc
donc ce sont toutes des produits qui
sont transportés par train dans le cas
du propane spécifiquement effectivement
le propane et transportés par train à
peu près 85 % pour le québec et pour
l'est du canada
et donc on a vu l'eau des grands
fournisseurs qui déclarent qu'ils sont
près de l'utilisation limites de leur
inventaire donc les réserves s'épuisent
de jour en jour
parce qu'on n'est pas capable
d'approvisionner en raison des chemins
de fer qui semble acquis exact avant moi
on avait parlé à l'automne d'une pénurie
en raison de la grève du cn mais bon
c'était les producteurs de grains et qui
avait besoin de propane là en ce moment
ils sont où les besoins en protéines
les besoins sont principalement pour le
chauffage alors ils ont que 80 quelques
pourcents du propane qui en ce moment
utilisé au québec et dans l'est est
utilisée pour le chauffage de maison le
chauffage d'entreprises d'institutions
d'écoles de maisons de personnes âgées
on parle surtout et principalement de
chauffage donc si ça ne se règle pas
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui va arriver
écoutez même si on a des plans pour
aller chercher du probable par camion il
ya une limite la quantité étant quand
même importante à ce stade si on peut
pas compenser par le transport par
camion alors effectivement on va espérer
que la situation serait aujourd'hui
parce qu'on voit la quantité de
probantes et acheminés par trains en
atlantique ces six cent mille litres par
jour
dix sept mille résidences qui en
dépendent 3000 étions & commerce est
également
est ce qu'il ya des priorités qui vont
être déterminée pour qui va recevoir ce
qui reste dans les réserves dans les
provinces maritimes donc en atlantique
c'est plutôt les camps les chacun des
commerçants qui va déterminer selon sa
liste de clients les priorités alors
effectivement les personnes âgées les
institutions les entreprises agricoles
qui ont besoin pour chauffer les animaux
passent généralement priorité des
centres par exemple le traitement des
eaux usées ou le traitement des eaux
pour l'eau pour boire va également aussi
être priorisé et au québec il y un plan
plus global qui sera peut-être
effectivement mis en place et à ce
moment-là ans carla ont choisi de
prioriser et de centraliser les
ressources pour s'assurer que chacune de
ces institutions personnes maison
reçoivent du proprement parler chauffage
aujourd'hui fait extrêmement froid vous
me parlez
potable alors on voit que c'est vital
les conséquences sont importantes
comment vous regardez cette réunion qui
est prévu à 10 heures ce matin
l'écouté de notre point de vue est bien
qu'on soit pas des experts en matière de
relations avec les autochtones
c'est clair que on pense que le chemin
de fer est un infra structures qui est
absolument essentiel est que au delà de
cette période si il faudra qu'il ya
débat plus large sur le rôle de
l'infrastructure au canada et comment on
la protège
pour toutes sortes de raisons parce que
ça crée de l'incertitude auprès des gens
de savoir qui les produits qui sont
peut-être pas libre et que leurs
entreprises ne peuvent pas fonctionner
mais également parce que du point de vue
de l'exportation du point de vue
également aussi de comment se positionne
vis-à-vis les autres on a de l'air un
peu disons un pays qui a peut-être un
peu moins de sécuriser sécurisé à cet
aspect de cet aspect là êtes vous
d'accord avec le gouvernement trudeau
qui donne la chance au dialogue et à une
sortie de crise pacifique où vous
opteriez comme l'opposition
par exemple les conservateurs qui
réclame l'intervention des policiers de
la grc
mais écoutez nous ce qu'on souhaite
c'est que ça se règle le plus rapidement
possible qui est qu'on ne prennent pas
en otage non plus une population versus
une autre nation alors je pense que les
partis devraient raisonnablement lever
les blocus et s'asseoir et continuer de
discuter saga merci beaucoup merci le
voir